So both of these mutations are nonsense mutations meaning they
both introduce stop codons. But one happens much sooner than the
other one does. So it's most likely to be more
severe. Think about it for a second. The earlier the mutation,
the nonsense mutation that comes in the sequence, the shorter
the overall protein's going to be. Which means if this nonsense
mutation happens at the very end of the sequence, okay
well we're not going to lose very much of our protein.
But if it happens way up front, towards the beginning
of the sequence, then yeah we're going to lose a lot
of the proteins and it's probably going to have a major
effect because we're missing far more amino acids. Again while this
is a general rule, it is possible that sometimes there's
not as big of a difference, because you could imagine there's
certain parts of proteins that are more important than others. And
so even when you delete big stretches not too much happens.
Still, in general, the sooner or the earlier a stop codon happens, a nonsense
mutation, the worse effect it's going to
have on the function of the overall protein.